hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're
going to be going over a fun little trap
in the king's gambit my favorite opening
in all of chess and that is the norwal
trap and it's in the king's game of
decline line so the kings game it starts
out with e4 e5 and then f4 accepted line
would be just taking on f4 but there's a
lot of different variations you could
come up against in the decline lines you
have your
d6 a lot of people play d5 the faulkner
counter game but you have just your
normal knight to f6 here you can see
some crazy stuff in the king's gambit
one of those is the norwald and that is
queen to f6 now first we have to think
about what they're actually trying to do
the immediate threat that they have
is if they don't think that you know how
to play against this you could
potentially play pawn takes on e5 that
would be a huge mistake because then
they can play queen to h4 this is their
immediate threat because how do we stop
this okay if we play king e2 that just
seems absolutely terrible if we play g3
then we've completely lost because queen
takes on e4 and then queen e2 and we've
lost our rook on h1 so we're not going
to play pawn takes on e5 obviously
we're going to be looking to get as much
material involved into the game and
attack our opponent so knight to f3
is going to be our
immediate response
but from here they're also threatening
the f4 pawn so instead of taking with
their pawn they're going to take with
their queen and they have protection
from their pawn now it doesn't really
matter too much they have protection uh
because it's the queen hey if we can
trade off that queen with any other
piece that's gonna be fine with us but
the queen is now attacking the pawn we
already looked at this e4 pawn is
vulnerable because not only would we
lose it it's also
the key square that's defending the king
on e1 so we need to play knight to c3
great development move also defends the
pawn on e4
best move from black is just play bishop
to b4 getting the dark square bishop
involved into the game as well as
attacking the knight on c3 many times if
you have to look at the setup and see
okay what's the important square right
now it's currently e4
and then how's my opponent defending
that we're defending it why it is with
knight to c3 so always trying to attack
the pieces that are defending the
critical squares
but here's the thing we do not care
instead we are going to continue with
our mission of being extremely
aggressive that's why you play the kings
game you're you're willing to give up
material so that you have these strong
attacks it starts with bishop to c4 and
we say we don't care if you take our
knight on c3 which is defending the e4
square we're going to be looking to
attack your weakest square and that is
f7 early on in the game so yeah if they
want to take our knight on c3 which is
the the best move for black for sure
none of these are well i don't know if
they're actually going to play that if
they're playing the norwald with queen
to f6 these are all the main lines that
you'll see
from black but in this spot we're not
going to capture
this bishop on c3 instead we're going to
continue to develop and we're going to
castle on the king side so there's a lot
of things one it takes the king off the
e1 square because that queen coming to
e1 or to e4
is difficult to deal with
second thing it does you can see it
lines up this rook
and the king's gambit what's always nice
is once you castle this rook is going to
be in a semi-open file and this f file
is very dangerous because we also have
our bishop on c4 attacking so we have
both our bishop we have our rook and
then as soon as our knight moves doesn't
matter if it comes to g5 or e5
that's going to be hitting this f7
square as well so a lot of threats on
the board for white now how does black
respond from here well really they need
to
move their bishop back because if they
don't not only can we capture their
bishop but we're capturing it with tempo
meaning once we take the bishop we're
also opening up for the dark square
bishop to attack their queen so it makes
sense to go ahead and move the bishop
back so they don't lose a piece and
allow us to gain a tempo so bishop to b4
but we're not looking to play c3 we're
not we don't care about the fact that we
gave up a knight on c3 that's not our
aim here we're trying to be as
aggressive as possible and so that is
the move d4 opening up with our dark
shore bishop to now attack the queen on
f4 now we're going to be looking at two
variations once we attack the queen one
is just if they take on e4 and the other
is if they don't take and maybe they
play queen to g4 they don't have a lot
of options if you can kind of look on
the board set they can't come to
g5 or h6 because the bishop is just
attacking these dark squares they can't
come to f5
and because of our pawn and they can't
come over here to h4 because of our
knight and things get pretty tricky if
they try to stay on this f file because
of our rook on f1 so first thing we're
going to look at is queen takes on e4
now as soon as they do this we are all
in they've already fallen for the trap
just by playing normal moves in the
opening which is great because sometimes
you watch a video or you see a trap and
you say oh they would never do that or
if they don't fall further strapped and
we're in a tough spot that's not the
case here in the norwal trap they're
playing very logical moves and
for the most part across the board
they're playing the main line but they
just come into a tough spot it's not the
best defense that black has against the
king's gambit but you just need to know
how to attack it properly so in this
spot we're going to take on f7 with our
bishop
now it's really bad if they take with
their king
bad for black it's very good for white
because we just have to move knight g5
you can see we're forking the queen so
as soon as the king moves we're gonna
capture the queen on e4 definitely not
gonna be a good thing so
uh once we take with our bishop on f7
they really need to play uh d8 you don't
want to keep it on this f file our rook
on f1 is just going to absolutely
dominate remember we gave up the knight
on f on c3 don't even care we're gonna
get that back uh with some interest so
king two d8 we're gonna capture on
g8 rook takes and then we're gonna get
our dark square bishop involved into the
game you can see we're so
much better at getting all of our pieces
working together they're king completely
in the middle just getting attacked the
queen here on e4 it finally got to the
square it wanted to it's not doing a
whole lot the bishop on b4 it's not
really working with any other piece and
the rook on g8 is just hanging out okay
so how do they continue from here it
seems pretty logical to bring the bishop
back
if they can just exchange off some
material that feels like a win but after
we take we can
now come up knight to e5 and this is a
spot that there's a lot of ways that
black can continue i'm gonna go over two
of them and just show you the fact that
black is completely lost in this
position one is if they look at this and
say okay let's go ahead and
attack the knights
one would be to play pawn to d6
and then white has the move rook to e1
so now the queen's under attack and they
don't have a lot of good squares if
they move pretty much anywhere they
can't come up to g6 but
if they move anywhere now we have a
discovered attack once we move our
knight a discovered check even which is
which is even better so to give you one
example let's say they play queen to f5
they want to keep it centrally located
as much as possible but now we can just
play
knight to c6 okay discover check here
attacking the king now where does the
king really go to i don't have a lot of
good options maybe king to d7 attacking
the knight but you can see that we
control the e file with our rook so now
we have moves like knight to e7 this is
forking the queen and the rook all
things good for white all things bad for
black so that's definitely not going to
work now if we come back and say what if
they don't play pawn to
d6 what if they try to attack this
knight with
their knight okay well now we can
actually just take
pretty freely here
and they don't have
a lot of great options as far as how
they they would respond because you know
if they just take with their pawn on c6
well then we have rook to e1
and their queen's gonna fall because we
now control this e-file they can't move
their queen
so yeah there's going to be exchange
here and white's in a pretty easy
comfortable spot here they could decide
well what if we just take
the knights with our queen but this
isn't going to work as well either
because of the move queen to h5 and it
looks a little weird you're like well
how does this actually
uh help
you have to keep in mind that they they
can't really move
well one of the threats is we have queen
two e5 another threat that we have is
rook to f7 being defended by the queen
and we can also get our other rook
involved in the game so they can't play
anything with their queen on the e file
because you know queen to e6 and then we
just have rook to e1 and they're gonna
lose the queen okay so that's not an
option for them so maybe they decide um
let's not move our queen at all what
what if we just play pawn to d5 this
opens up for our bishop to get involved
into the game but then we have rook to
f7 and you can start to see the threats
that we have here queen or king back to
d8
queen to
maybe they come over with their queen
here but then our rook takes uh pawn
takes then we take their queen there's
really just no escape from them it's
just going to go completely
bad from their standpoint okay so let's
come back from the to the very beginning
we looked at if their queen takes on e4
and the different variations you could
see now let's look at what happens if
they play queen to
g4 in this spot
so similar to if they took on e4 as soon
as they play queen to g4 we're going to
take the pawn on f7
now we already looked at why it's bad if
they take here because we could play
knight to e5 we're forking the queen and
that's gonna be a pretty easy game for
white now if they play king to d8
the slight difference in the variation
is we're going to play h3 this is
essentially forcing their hand
and to say how do you want to respawn
now if they play queen to e4
this is going down the same path that
we've seen before because now we just
take on g8 they take with their rook we
play bishop to
g5 and you've seen this variation before
now if they don't take on e4 maybe they
decide to play queen to g3
okay well now we're still going to take
on a g8
now we've always looked at what happens
if the rook takes on g8 so let's look at
one other way they could try to continue
in some of these variations and i'm
showing it in this example but
it'll apply in the others as well they
played knight to c6
okay well now we're just gonna keep
going with the same game plan bishop to
g5 you can see all of our pieces playing
so well together this knight is
defending the bishop you can see the
rook is controlling this entire f-file
our queen can get involved into the game
especially when the knight moves we have
some very very powerful attacks with the
queen coming to g4 and h5 at any given
time
so now we're attacking
the king on d8
so more than likely bishop comes back to
e7 but now we have the move knight to e5
capturing that pawn here and if you look
at it how will they continue okay well
if they take our bishop which is the
immediate threat that's pinning down the
bishop to the king if they take here
well now we can come up knight to f7
check and forking the rook on
h8 so king to e7 and we just capture on
h8 now if we come back and say what if
they don't take the bishop on g5
what if they just try to take our
knights
okay that we're they're still protected
from this bishop but this is actually
going to be checkmate so they lose with
rook to f8 so you can see all the
different landmines at the very
beginning they thought they were pretty
cute because we tried the king's gambit
and they said hey
we have the norwald and this is this is
uh our way that we're gonna try to
attack you because we don't know if
you're actually a kings gambit
professional
and we
have other things in store for them
because we know exactly how to attack it
now
with the norwald trap so hopefully you
guys enjoyed this video i love doing
videos on the king's gambit because i
think in chess it's all about finding
your favorite openings and then studying
everything about those for me that's the
king's gambit at the top of the list
i've tried to go through pretty much all
the variations so that when i play i
feel extremely comfortable it doesn't
matter if it's an accepted game decline
line does not matter i love all the
traps that are involved extremely
aggressive which fits my personality
so hopefully if you are a kingsgamer fan
as well if you ever run into this you'll
know exactly how to counter so thanks
again for watching i'll see you guys in
the next video have a good one
you